there's no sign yet of a deal in
Congress to prevent a possible
government shutdown current funding runs
out April 28th which is about four weeks
away and Congress will be in recess for
two of those weeks so time is running
short only on CBS this morning we asked
House Speaker Paul Ryan how he's working
to avoid another legislative setback the
government will shut down on April 29th
unless you pass a funding bill will it
to fund Planned Parenthood well that's
in our Obamacare legislation so we think
the Smith the smart way to go is to
reconciliation because that only
requires 50 votes it takes 60 votes to
defund Planned Parenthood in the Senate
if you go through appropriations I don't
think there are 60 votes you don't want
the plan defunding a plan and we want
that to be in our reconciliation not in
the funding bill it's yeah it's
reconciliation is where we have the best
chance of getting it done let me just
say this we're talking about shutting
down the government No
and you hear people in the freedom
caucus and they're saying we want the
defunding of Planned Parenthood in this
funding bill will shut down the
government it's in our Obama care
replacement bill and that bill can't be
filibustered that's the smart place to
put it and that's where we have a chance
of doing it let me just say this Nora
we're not gonna have a government
shutdown the president isn't one I have
a government shutdown its funding the
government from April 28th to September
30th so that funding bill doesn't need
to include new money for the wall the
border walk well of course the DHS needs
money for border security so that will
be in there there's always money for
border security well I know and what I
meant was additional money for the wall
a big chunk of money for the wall really
is next year's next fiscal year's
appropriations because they literally
can't start construction even this
quickly who's driving the agenda on tax
reform is at the White House or
republican well I think it's a
collaborative effort it's it's the House
Ways and Means Committee it's the Senate
Finance Committee which are the primary
drivers in Congress and the White House
the president spokesperson just said
it's the White House that's driving it
well that's fine with me I don't I don't
really care who's driving it I just as
fine as we get to an agreement and get
it done so it's really a three-way
conversation but the trunk tax plan and
the Ryan tax plan is different well it's
not a Ryan tax tonight's the house
blueprint that every house Republican
ran on but we all knew that well I
helped Kevin Brady really our Chairman
always means but I worked on this when I
was chair we always knew this was the
beginning of the process you never go
into the legislative process says here's
my plan take it or leave it
how's your
relationship with President Trump very
good we talk frequently actually uh
actually we've you know we didn't know
each other very well or if at all before
the election but we've established a
very good relationship every day yeah
just about how long don't know about a
half hour ago and what do you talk about
just the policies of the day we're
talking about health care these days
talk about tax reform a lot of things
did you guys talk at all about that
tweet he sent out to watch a show on Fox
where the anchors yeah he called me and
he said look at that he actually was
very apologetic about it in that he said
I had no idea that that's what she was
going to talk about I thought she was
going to talk about something else so
really that would that was completely
coincidental and I know and I believe he
was right when he says that he thought
she was gonna talk about something
either sector Russia that he thought was
interesting and favorable he had no idea
she was gonna do that but hey this job
you take a lot of take a lot I knew this
is gonna be the last job I took in
politics because I mean I'm happy with
I'm totally comfortable with that
because it's an opportunity to make a
big difference get things done and this
is one of those jobs where you take a
bunch of slings and arrows and you just
know that when you take this job you
take it with a grain of salt it really
doesn't get to me anymore
I thought about you last week and I
thought how you might have ended the
week when you went home to Wisconsin you
know what happened I am another week my
wife texted me as I was going to the
flying home to O'Hare I go to O'Hare and
then drive to Wisconsin from there
she said you picked the wrong land to
give up drinking beer you need a beer
I thought about you I've known you long
and you're having an extra beer yeah
they gave it up for Lent and then what
do I do I get home for halftime with a
badger game and we lose to Florida in
overtime with the last second
three-point shot it was you know that
was a tough day that's a really tough
day you can see he has a good attitude
about humor is still very much intact
yeah yeah wants to get stuff done and
it's interesting to hear about his
relationship with President Trump
they're talking on the phone a lot they
want to get this done and you remember
that when they first talked about making
him Speaker of the House he was somewhat
resistant did want it yes he was that's
exactly right he talked about his family
life do you believe me as someone who's
known him a long time and he says he's
okay with the slings and arrows he knows
it comes with the territory I do
you have to have a tough so yeah yeah
and I think he knows too having served
in Congress for a while not only as a
congressman but a staffer before that
that legislating takes time you know it
takes a time and so but they've got a
tight timeline they want to get a lot
done by August Obamacare which is back
on the table and tax reform based on
what the president says also there's
reason to believe that it is much more
communication yeah he said don't let
perfect be the enemy of good
they want to get stuff doing I like that